>> Chris: IT'S TIME FOR THE
FIGHTERS CLUB ROAST.
SINCE "STAR WARS: THE FORCE
AWAKENS" WAS ANNOUNCED --
-- DID I MENTION THAT I'M
GOING TO THE PREMIERE TONIGHT?
I'M GOING TO THE [BEEP]
PREMIERE. I CAN'T EVEN CONTAIN
MYSELF. I CAN'T -- AHH -- SHUT
UP CHRIS HARDWICK!
THIS HAS BEEN DOMINATING THE
CONVERSATIONS ONLINE.
THERE ARE EVEN STAR WARS GRAPES!
STAR WARS GRAPES: FOR WHEN YOU
WANT TO PRETEND YOU'RE EATING
YODA'S BALLS.
STAR WARS GRAPES.
EAT MY BALLS YO WILL.
NOW, I'M AS EXCITED AS THE NEXT
NERD ABOUT THIS MOVIE, BUT I DO
THINK "STARS WARS" COULD STAND
TO BE TAKEN DOWN A PEG, SO WE'RE
-- I DON'T AGREE EITHER.
FOR THIS BIT WE'RE DOING A
INTERGALACTIC ROAST.
COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO GIVE
EACH OF YOU A SET OF "STAR WARS"
CHARACTERS FROM THE "STAR WARS"
WIKI, WOOKIEEPEDIA, AND FOR 250
POINTS, YOU'RE GONNA ROAST THEIR
GOOFY MUGS.
JESSE, CHEWBACCA.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE A
SASQUATCH AND YOU LIVE IN
A SPACESHIP. YOU'RE LIKE A
REDNECK UNICORN.
THERE MUST BE A LINE AROUND THE
BLOCK OF HICKS TRYING TO GET
[BEEP] IN THE ASS BY YOU.
>> Chris: NOT SURE HOW I FEEL
ABOUT THAT WITH THIS SWEATER.
NEXT UP PONDA BABA.
>> ARE YOU CHOKING ON A
KARDASHIAN.
[LAUGHING]
>> YOU'RE THE ONLY STAR WARS
CHARACTER GETTING HIS TEETH
CLEANED AT THE GYNECOLOGIST.
>> Chris: KU, YOU HAVE YODA.
>> YODA, MY GOD. HE'S SO
ADORABLE AND UGLY AT THE SAME
TIME.
IT'S LIKE IT'S MR. MIAGI AND ET
HAD SEX THAT'S WHAT YODA WOULD
BE.
>> Chris: WHICH ONE GOT
PREGNANT?
>> Chris: NEXT UP ADMIRAL
ACKBAR.
>> WAY TO MAKE EVERY SPACE SHIP
SMELL LIKE FISH.
>> Chris: HE GETS YOU IN THERE,
AND THEN -- IT'S A TRAP!
AL, FIRST UP FROM THE FORCE
AWAKEN, KYLO REN.
>> OH, KYLO. WHAT'S UP? YOU'RE A
NEWCOMER BRO.
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT
YOU.
I LIKE YOUR NAME, KYLO REN.
THE ONLY VILLAIN WHO SEEMS LIKE
YOU WERE NAMED BY A HOLLYWOOD
SUPER COUPLE.
YOUR NAME'S KYLE? NO IT'S KYLO,
KILL YOURSELF.
WE DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT
YOU EXCEPT THAT YOU'RE BLACK.
WHICH IS ALL ANYBODY KNOWS ABOUT
ME IN THIS AUDIENCE.
>> KEEP IT MOVING.
Chris: NEXT UP WICKET.
>> I CAN'T MAKE FUN OF SOMETHING
THIS CUTE. HE'S ADORABLE.
>> Chris: HE'S A SAVAGE, HE'D
EAT YOU IF HE HAD THE CHANCE,
AL.
>> NO MATTER WHAT THEY SAY I
LIKE YOU.
WE STILL FRIENDS EVEN THOUGH YOU
DON'T FALL FOR THE PEANUT BUTTER
TRICK LIKE MY DOG DOES.
AT LEAST NOT YET.